click cyclic cyclic sick what up fam
it's me for us lawns
I'm Grace's cousin I've been on this
channel once before guys like savage
request to have me back it's so savage
and live average we call boys favorite
class average good sorry I was too smart
for a second I will retract my previous
job I realize the people on YouTube have
been naming their fan bases as if to
create some sort of like pseudo militia
it's a little bit concerning but the
thing that I'm more concerned about is
that we don't have a family name but I
got you I'm Forrest lon you guys are my
overly obsessed fans so I'm gonna call
you lawn gnomes like this you get at
home deep pot or low a little bit on the
cake I'm working on music video music my
boy Jake Paul released a diss track not
diss track I hear it is [ __ ] the
audience left you smart I'll attract I
haven't seen it so I'm gonna watch it
and react to it with you guys right now
go on gnome
Jake Paul YouTube stars dis track oh oh
and the thumbnail he's got photos of all
these huge youtube stars and I bet
that's super misleading and like none of
them are even mentioned this isn't a
diss track it's a message to all the
news and hate Jake oh he can write in
cursive we're both women sports you see
how strong is Nisa ripped through both
genes you got strong knees power from
sucking older dude just get in
what [ __ ] oh oh he's shopping in the
liquor aisle wheeze in the liquor aisle
you know some oh the fires of fire
tracks have been shot inside a grocery
store kid from a small town
Oh important he's like the only kid from
a small town so he's been through
struggle no one else is from a small
town the way that Jake Paul is from a
small town oh I feel the struggle in the
news Oh
in a news we're gonna keep going [ __ ] I
know the pain oh oh wait did you see
that he said the word verbally but in
the subtitles he he put stars but he
said it but he censored it in the title
because deaf people he kissed about oh
let fire lit fire I don't know your
password
[Music]
I didn't get invited directly it seems
like you were the only person there
doing meals for kids on Thanksgiving so
I give that to you and only you that you
were the only person there making
charity meals for kids on Thanksgiving
and you're probably the only person
that's ever done that ever in the world
I didn't get invited you handing out
backpacks and t-shirts to those kids
infinitely more charitable than what a
teacher's normal day-to-day job is for
the pay that she gets and the work that
she puts in constantly and consistently
oh you better [ __ ] oh using a very
sincere situation I'm manipulating it to
make you look better rather than shine a
good light on a great cause oh and then
straight back to the aluminum aisle of
the grocery store like it never happened
Oh illegally driving your car in a video
that's supposed to make you seem nice
and confusing messaging that fire lit
fire you got Rihanna on this track watch
whoa you just said that you know you're
caulking or try not to be but the visual
imagery was you driving illegally with
your car and a way that suggests you are
encouraging dangerous activities
Oh continuous mixed messages we didn't
go to school together you were probably
the only one in the lunchroom I would
assume because you're the only one from
a small town that had small town
struggles but apparently had other kids
in your town that you stopped from
getting bullied you weren't getting
bullied it sounds like in your small
town so maybe your lap what's actually
pretty good to begin with and you the
struggle might be just some sort of
delusion in your head or some sort of
shallow attempt to get sympathy I don't
know I'm just spitballing here like this
track oh I got so much - Celina when she
left Disney
she just didn't tweet me back that we
only know where you put on the internet
for us otherwise it's called stalking
[Music]
HPV
these giant even crossing on the
crosswalk this kid lives life
dangerously so where two different color
shoes this is what finish it oh and a
link to buy the song because if you're
gonna apologize genuinely and want
people to sympathize with you being a
human being
McDuck cash money don't forget to
subscribe to this YouTube channel if you
want more videos let grace know that you
want forest lawns to be back with more
content for my lawn gnomes that's it I
gotta go cuz I'm too amplifier fire
[ __ ] dick fire [ __ ] lit I'm gonna say
something I regret so before I do that
I'm gonna go find a group of friends
that are slightly above average
attractiveness and see if I can
manipulate them into making me Monday I
don't know sorry gnomes just had to
admire the beauty that is my face for a
second just want to feel what it's like
to be you